mais que louis aucoin stratèges en
communication et gestion de crise jouer
au coin bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors avec cet
accord est ce que londres veut t'envoyer
un signal à bruxelles finalement en
montrant qu'elle peut signer des accords
commerciaux d'elle même et se
débrouiller sans l'union européenne
alors c'est fort possible et puis
c'était en fait c'est surtout important
pour le canada cet accord leur faut se
rendre compte que le canada exporte deux
fois plus qu il importe de la grande
bretagne
donc c'était très attendu ici d'avoir
une certitude à l'effet que c'est encore
le même s'il est temporaire allait être
renouvelé pour le 1er janvier
il ya beaucoup de voix qui s'élèvent au
canada qui demande plus de détails
concernant cet accord la sédré mais
l'aspect le plus important pour que vous
sachiez ce sont ces la question des
produits laitiers qui est une industrie
extrêmement importante au canada et la
crainte était d'ouvrir la porte à
l'importation de nouveaux produits
laitiers d une crainte qui s'était en
fait qu'ils continuent de faire la
gronde ici dans l'économie parce que
avec l'accord avec l'union européenne
on ne permis l'importation produits
laitiers ici et il a une stricte demain
est très étendue pour y jouer vous
l'expliquer pour l'instant le contenu de
l'accord restent connus mais les deux
pays ont annoncé vouloir négocier un
texte pour des échanges plus poussés à
quoi cela pourrait-il ressembler quel
bien échange le canada pourra échanger
un le canada et le royaume uni dans les
biens les plus importants pour le canada
c'est l'aéronautique
donc il ya une très importante du rap
aéronautique en particulier au québec et
même pour le pour le canada le royaume
uni représente le cinquième pays avec
lequel on a des échanges mais pour le
québec c'est le quatrième pays donc le
québec je voudrais en contrepartie à une
relation encore plus importante que le
canada avec le royaume uni en
particulier à cause de tout le secteur
aéronautique
cette industrie là est important pour
l'économie ici et c'est pour ça qu'on
est encore là était très attendue gérer
que peut-être la moitié des échanges
qui ont fait entre le canada et le
royaume uni ils sont faits au québec
donc c'est c'était un accord
effectivement très important mais ce
qu'on nous annonce aujourd'hui c'est
temporaire en matière c'est temporaire
et on a très attrayante au canada en
connaître plus sur cet accord là on
comprend quand même que c'est des
négociations bilatérales donc ça prend
toujours quelques mois avant d'aboutir
des négociations également importante
pour boris johnson est ce qu'il est en
train de chercher lui aussi des
partenaires commerciaux à tout prix
finalement hors de l'union européenne à
tout prix je sais pas mais certainement
que boris johnson a besoin de succès
dans ses relations internationales est
certain qu'avec le canada il ya un
partenaire de choix comme membre du
commonwealth et aussi comme partenaire
économique majeur
donc c'est pas nécessairement un appui
politique envers boris johnson mais
c'est certain que ya un intérêt commun
l'intérêt politique pour le premier
ministre britannique mais un intérêt
économique pour le canada
et cet intérêt commun la je pense donc
continuer va se poursuivre dans les
prochains mois donc c'est disons que
c'est une bonne nouvelle de notre côté
de l'atlantique et du coup c'est est ce
que cette signature selon vous elle
pourrait donner un coup d'accélérateur
aux négociations commerciales pour le
bric site ou au contraire freiné la
discussion en fait je pense que ça
crédibilise en grande partie la position
de boris johnson de dire il ya la
possibilité pour la grande bretagne de
poser ces gestes loeb bilatéraux mais je
en grande partie oui mais enfin c'est
limité parce que quand vous tenez quand
vous convenez de cet accord avec un
membre du commonwealth
on va dire que c'était quand même un
accord peut-être plus facile à obtenir
qu'avec avec d'autres pays ont que pour
boris johnson france est important
politiquement c'est important de
l'annoncé à ce moment si important de
l'annoncé au g20 s'annonce important de
l'annoncer avant la fin de l'année
c'était très attendu ça va faire parler
dans les cirques économique mais ça va
en prendre d'autres imaginent pour
influencer un peu plus bruxelles et pour
conclure quels sont les relations entre
l'union européenne et le canada
aujourd'hui relations économiques
mais direz qu'ils relèvent leur assure
économiques vont bien vous allez me
prendre en défaut sur les chiffres
exacts de nos de l'état de nous de nos
exportations importations mais par
contre au canada on a quand même depuis
2007 cet accord avec l'union européenne
et cet accord l'homme même s'il a fait
grincer des dents un peu dans certaines
industries
dans l'ensemble il satisfait beaucoup de
monde et je pense que chacun y trouve
son compte pour le moment le fait qu'il
ya une maintenance c'est tentant de
bilatérales avec le royaume uni c'est
important de savoir que avec l'ensemble
de l'europe des relations canadiennes
sont nés et sont maintenus de façon
stable ce qui favorise le commerce qui
favorise les échanges et la
prévisibilité pour nos entreprises donc
beaucoup de satisfactions de ce côté là
en ce moment merci beaucoup louis aucoin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes stratèges en
communication et gestion de crise